EFFORTS TO OVERTURN THE
ELECTION.
NEW DETAILS ON HOW THE CRIMINAL
PROBE HAS EVOLVED FROM CNN'S
SARAH MARIE.
>> AND BATTLEGROUND STATES
ACROSS THE COUNTRY, GOP
ACTIVIST REPUBLICAN PARTY
CHAIRS AND EVEN A STATE SENATE
PRESIDENT.
>> I'M THE SENATE PRESIDENT OF
ARIZONA, AND IT'S OUR JOB TO
MAKE SURE WE HAVE FAIR AND
ACCURATE ELECTIONS.
>> THEY ARE GETTING HIT WITH
SUBPOENAS.
AS EARLY AS THIS WEEK, SOME
REPUBLICANS TIE TO THE
PLAINTIFF PUT FORWARD THEY
COLLECTORS FOR TRUMP ARE SET TO
TURN OVER INFORMATION TO
FEDERAL INVESTIGATORS.
>> WE HAVE SOMETHING THEY THINK
IS A CRIME, THEY WILL BRING AN
INDICTMENT AND THAT'S WHEN YOU
WILL FIND OUT WHAT THEY ARE
DOING.
>> THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENTS
INVESTIGATION BEGAN WITH THE
VIOLENCE THAT ERUPTED AT THE
CAPITOL.
CHARGES AGAINST MORE THAN 800
ALLEGED RIOTERS, INCLUDING THE
LEADERS OF THE PROUD BOYS AND
OATH KEEPERS.
IN RECENT MONTHS, IT'S EXPANDED
TO COVER THE FAKE ELECTOR
SCHEME AND SEVEN BATTLEGROUND
STATES, WITH SUBPOENAS TO
PROMINENT REPUBLICANS, GEORGIA
CHAIRMAN DAVID SHAPER AND PARTY
CHAIR KELLY WARD.
>> DO NOT LET THIS ELECTION BE
STOLEN.
>> THE PROBE INCHING CLOSER TO
TRUMP AS INVESTIGATORS RATED
JEFFREY CLARK PHONE, THE FORMER
OFFICIAL WHO PUSHED DONALD
TRUMP'S VOTER FRAUD CLAIMS.
>> EVEN BROUGHT ALONG SOMETHING
I'VE NEVER SEEN BEFORE OR HEARD
OF, AND ELECTRONIC SNIFFING DOG
AND THEY TOOK ALL OF THE
ELECTRONICS FROM MY HOUSE.
>> ALSO SEES ELECTRONICS FROM
ATTORNEY JOHN EASTMAN, WHO
PEDDLED BASELESS FRAUD CLAIMS
AND PUSHED A LEGAL THEORY THAT
PARENTS COULD BLOCK THE
CERTIFICATION.
>> ALL WE ARE DEMANDING A VICE
PRESIDENT PENCE, IS THIS
AFTERNOON AT 1:00, HE LET THE
LEGISLATORS OF THE STATE LOOK
INTO THIS.
>> BE ON THE DOJ PRO, A
SEPARATE CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION
IS ESCALATING IN GEORGIA WHERE
INVESTIGATORS SUBPOENAED KEY
TRUMP ALLIES. THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY SAID MORE SUBPOENAS
MAY BE HEADED TO TRUMP'S INNER
CIRCLE.
>> WE ARE GOING TO DO OUR DUE
DILIGENCE.
>> UNEARTHING NEW DETAILS LIKE